Vorsicht zerbrechlich das klebe ich
immer normalerweise auf Pakete wo ich
Glas drin verschicke drauf aber jetzt
gibt es ein Album das so heiß und zwar
das von Doreen äh die Freundin von Sido
die mit ihm ja auch einen sensationelles
Duett hatte nein ganz vorne in schwarz
gewesen äh hat Popstars gewonnen und
jetzt ihr Album Vorsicht zerbrechlich
darüber werden wir mit ihr reden und
natürlich über eure oder sie wird eure
Nutzer Fragen beantworten wenn Sie
kreativ sind am besten als Videoantwort
so ist das bei Youtube hochladen eure
nutzerfragen hier ist ein Link im Video
wenn ich es nicht vergesse und unten ins
Kommentar vielleicht klicken da gibt's
dann auch ein Button daneben und wenn
ihr dann nichts verpassen wollt von
Doreen hier oben müsste irgendwo der Abo
Knopf sein abonnieren klicken und
ansonsten empfehle ich Infotext lesen ja
kreativ dann halt schon gesagt und dann
drücke ich die Daumen dass er dran kommt
und ich glaube Dorin wird sich freuen
über eure Fragen je nachdem